what's up world should play a part in  checking in to China  you know me I'm flamboyant our looks  expensive Georgia I like fancy things  like martini on the rocks and I'm always  craving for something more because  you're on the name and a $5,000  hey I need a new slip my game put it on  to change Ted French got monkeys in New  York I think I'm full-blown I love magic  not much both of these if I wanted to  deal I have diamond in piece vodka I  know is expensive no no it's quality  it's a work of art their chandeliers in  a bum  this is the biggest pipe in the world  when I show you what I'm about to show  you you'll understand why I have to make  sure I'm secure at all times  Wow the most expensive on the water this  will experience cost Wow this is the new  seat of the most expensive issue